there's a lot of people in florida who
are you know fans of florida with what's
going on with florida but i haven't met
anybody that admires and loves the
sentence as much as you
why is that
what's the reasoning why you love the
governor so much like i'm really curious
we don't have only an hour right i'm
actually curious why do you love this
man so much you know it's interesting
you know when we first got elected uh
all four of us on the cabinet so for
those who don't know the cabinet
consists of the governor uh the chief
financial officer the attorney general
and the commission of agriculture and i
was actually really hopeful you know all
four of us were under the age of 50 all
had younger families and i really was
like okay great maybe there's an
opportunity for us to show the rest the
country what bipartisan support looks
like we had a lot of mutual friends i
had known the attorney general since our
time in undergrad and law school knew
the cfo from when he was in the
legislature ashley right actually you
know was that jimmy patroness as well as
cfo yeah so i had known them all for i
was like okay we're gonna we're gonna do
this we're gonna do some good stuff
together
and i was really wrong i'm not wrong a
lot in my life but but this was this was
a big one and unfortunately uh you know
starting really kind of towards the
latter part of 2019 he just was coming
in there there was violations of
sunshine there was just not working with
everybody and the biggest thing started
really in 2020 when he tried to come in
and take my office of energy which falls
underneath the commissioner and we had
done some really really great things
under there and i was like why why wha
what's the point we're doing good stuff
and it came down to power and that's
when i realized this guy is no good that
he cares about one thing and one thing
only and that's how to get more power
and every decision that he's made since
then is how to consolidate power behind
the governor i mean look what he did to
the legislature this past week that he
made the senate president and the
speaker of the house stand next to him
as he vetoed 3.1 billion dollars and
laughed at them
that's not who a governor is supposed to
be and i've watched him become a
dictator and really try to consolidate
this power marginalize people
yell at our kids um all for his goal of
power and to get to the white house okay
so now you say that about him but tell
us
what are you running on so the audience
also knows what uh you're for yep
absolutely and that's more important
more important to know what the people
are running for so look we'll get into
both of them but i just want to make
sure they also know what you're for so i
have been our elected statewide democrat
for three and a half years and i have
been every single day fighting for the
people of our state making sure that
everybody's got to see the table making
sure that you know people that have been
marginalized before
know that there's someone fighting for
them and today we have a real serious
problem in our state
that we have seen that republicans
unfortunately and my dad's a republican
so i want to also be very clear i grew
up and as you were talking about before
on air that there's a you know communism
versus imperialism in your household my
dad is a die-hard republican when i was
doing soup kitchens and habitat for
humanity in miami growing up he was
getting me nra t-shirts so we are you
know that's kind of the household that i
grew up what was your mom she is a
die-hard democrat she was a teacher for
25 years and they're still together oh
no no no
that's not a good case example for
america there nikki
how long were they married for 25 years
five years wow
that's a long time a long time five
years
sometimes that 25 years is simply until
the kids turn 18. that's what they're
waiting for yeah
they got divorced twice my parents in in
20 years they married each other
divorced married each other divorced in
20 years wow so a similar story please
continue so so i was watching all of
this and at the end of the day that's
not what government's supposed to be
government is supposed to be able to
bring people together inspire people
making sure that everybody's got
economic opportunities get that american
dream of home ownership and living here
and government's staying out of the way
you know i've always again from my dad
was hot about what public republicans
are supposed to be about less government
less taxes less spending local control
free market the republicans of today
don't stand for any of that and seeing
again the government intrusion every
single day where i'm somebody i came in
i created the hemp program here in the
state of florida so first time we
created a new industry in our state and
i created an open market that leading
anybody who wants to cultivate to
manufacture to distribute
has an equal opportunity to succeed so i
look at things of how do i make people's
lives better not how do i go after
people how to make lives better and
unfortunately for you know what the
republicans have been doing for the last
you know a couple of years is dividing
us and so i come to the table said look
there's a better way to lead there's a
way to make sure that the people are are
the first priority making sure we're not
taking away people's rights to vote and
taking away people's rights to protest
and going after communities and most
importantly we have an economic disaster
happening in our state that people can't
afford to live here we become the number
one unaffordability we've surpassed
california and new york
that's been underneath these republican
leaders and so i say look at the end of
the day i want to come in i want to give
people an opportunity for that american
dream and to make sure that we're
creating policies that are going to give
opportunities so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]